don't ever forget wherever you go I'm
always with you
the world made of light and darkness you
can't have one without the other I don't
care who this organization is or what
it's planning there's nothing to worry
about right oh where there is some place
I want to go and someone I want to see
it has been far too
the Keyblade has no place in this or any
world sayin what has made his purpose
clear I am left with no choice and last
our moment is here I swore I would
survive and be there to see what awaited
beyond the Keyblade war
we don't know the bugs true form or
origin why it's even hear your said
soraa has to call these memories to the
surface visit time you'll just have to
look deep inside your hearts and that's
where you'll be able to find us the
words might disappear but never the
memories give me strength
you
hybrid 0 sin so tastier omegas libre
dots kya chahiye Carey Ohio Dante's
hasta gallon ando chee dasa yeah
bostonma staticky hats me Madonna doable
Akita conoce yamini items on toaster
you